Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P. Yesterday,
we covered the 27 vaccine refusal
dismissals in the Air Force, and I got an
interesting call about that. Listen to this,
Speaker 5: Mr Pacman, sir. Just some quick
information on the Air Force vaccination. I'm an
Air Force civilian and you mentioned the twenty
seven servicemembers that have been discharged
so far. Just a clarification. The those 27
are the ones that not only refuse the
vaccine, but also did not apply for a
religious or medical exemption.
Speaker 1: Apply for and
Speaker 2: get important
Speaker 1: message, too.
Speaker 5: And so there are still
many, many, many members in the Air
Force and the other services that are
going through the exemption process.
Most likely, they will all get declined,
at which point they will have to
have the same choice that the twenty seven
who have already been discharged had and will
either have to get out or or get vaccinated.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and that is a good point.
The all, as far as I know, all branches of
the military are being very strict about these
various exemptions and new recruits are being
forced to sign as a condition of even starting
that they understand they will be required
to get the COVID vaccine. So that's a
good point. The number may go up.
Speaker 2: It is still quite low.
Speaker 1: We've got a great
bonus show for you today.
Speaker 2: It's not looking like
Speaker 1: build back better is going to pass
this year. I don't know if many of you will be
Speaker 2: shocked by that, but it's not
Speaker 1: going to happen. We'll talk about
that. A New Zealand has a new cigaret ban that
is different than other countries we will talk
about. And also San Francisco Bay Area car break
ins are on the rise and some car owners are
leaving their trunks open. We will explain why
on today's bonus show. Sign up at join
Packman Icon. We will see you then.